You might have been wondering this whole time how exactly is D3 data driven.
And when do we manipulate our graphic based on our data?
Well without using Dimple JS we have to be rather explicit and
a little bit more verbose.
But are afforded much greater flexibility.
And you could pose a chart as a question like this.
How do I draw circle for
every row of my data at the appropriate place on my axises?
And the most natural answer to this question, at least in java script,
is exactly that, a for loop.
Again how do I draw a circle for every row of my data?
Well, we could iterate through every row in our data and
for each row draw our circle with the value of that row.
And while this is partially pseudocode,
this could be a perfectly sensible way to think about drawing a chart.
Dependent on data in a very JavaScripty way.
Notice how we have to be very explicit and procedural in how we
tell the computer to draw a circle for every row in our data.
But this seems a little bit cumbersome especially if the structure of
our data changes.
We want to use a different data file.
We want to draw a different shape altogether.
Or if we want our chart to adapt to some interaction from the user.
Very early on when I introduced D3 I
told you that one of the strengths of the library it's declarative syntax.
Or rather you tell D3 what you want rather than how you want it to do it.
Again in a pure JavaScript approach.
We have to be very procedural with the computer and
specify step by step what it needs to do to create our chart.
With D3 on the other hand we simply specify what we want,
circles, data in an SVG element.
And D3 figures out how to best draw our chart.
And one of the most mystical, yet powerful,
features of D3 is the data bind, performed through the .data function.
The data variable here is the same data variable that's passed to the call back
of our data loading function, such as D3.json, D3.csv,
or D3.tsv which loads our data file.
And if we inspect what data actually is, which we'll see in a little bit,
just as with our dimple example, it's simply a JavaScript array.
Filled with JavaScript objects that represent our external file we loaded.
Again, this chaining syntax is hopefully very familiar to you now.
Each subsequent function gets called on the previous return value,
transforming the object as it gets passed down the chain.
The first statement here find the SVG element on the page which we want.
And since there's only one, we simply need to use select.
We then sub-select all the circles contained in that SVG element but
let's pause here.
This is usually where it breaks down for people.
How can you select circles when if this is our first time drawing this
chart there won't be any circles on the page until we append them?
What are the circles that we're actually selecting.
Well if we simply select circles when there are none we get the empty selection.
Well then you might be asking,
if it's an empty section how can you bind data to nothing?
Well, I would argue, you bind the data to the circles that will be there.
Well, this might seem somewhat circular reasoning, no pun intended.
But let's break down and
really understand what's going on in this snippet of code.